bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france comment expliquer
ces tensions à la frontière entre israël
et le liban
cette tension et de la tension dans la
région du conflit en syrie ou israël est
impliqué bon dans ce conflit pour cette
crise avec les états unis
parce que c'est un enjeu régional et
international qui se joue entre deux
blocs le bloc atlantique idée par les
états unis et le le bloc asiatique qui
est la chine et la russie et l'iran
alors qu'elle se trouvait là pour israël
et qui entre deux de mener des coups
contre la syrie ils ont causé la mort
d'un combattant de l'esbva en syrie et
ils sa peau à une réaction
pour cette raison là le il est revenu
une déclaration de la part des
israéliens
il y avait eu une tentative
d'infiltration aux frontières de choses
que vous pas à nier avoir vite
l'explication c'est que les israéliens
être en train de draguer le haut-rhin
compris grand niveau
surtout que israël un prétexte pour
mener une opération militaire contre le
sida et contre la syrie pour achever un
objectif stratégique celui de port c'est
le liront et le hezbollah
or de la syrie chose que les israéliens
et les américains ont déjà demandé à
plusieurs bus des trams ou sur le rôle
du hezbollah le parti chiite
actif au liban et soutenu on le sait par
alliant oui bien sûr le hezbollah et
soutenue de résistance libanaise contre
israël qui étaient supportés par la
syrie et l'iran surtout dans les quatre
décennies dernière y compris d'autres
groupes de résistance mais c'était le
plus consistante en son combat contre
israël et il se considère faire partie
d'un axe de résistance inclut le
hezbollah la syrie et l'iran et qui sont
tous les deux tout les trois supporté
par les pas de la chine et la russie
posé dans un contexte de conflits au
niveau global contre les tentatives de
hégémonie américaine dans le monde parce
que la stratégie américaine est basée
sur la tentative de bloquer est
d'obstruer l'accès de l'asie aux voies
maritimes alors ce qui explique par
exemple la tension en ukraine en mer
noire
omer bhatti au maire de chiens à l'est
de l'asie
on est en même temps ce qui explique la
pension dans la série et même au yémen
alors ça fait parti d'un conflit global
et pour cette raison là il n'y a aucun
parti qui ne fait pas partie d'un prompt
à niveau international pour le liban
peut-être aussi un contentieux
territorial la région du monde off qui
est un enjeu aussi bien pour israël que
pour les autorités libanaises puisque
c'est un territoire qui revendiquait
depuis longtemps par le liban oui bien
sûr
gens de chez bras étaient occupés en
1967 lors de la guerre de six jours
malgré que le liban n'était pas impliqué
dans cette guerre la lra lien considère
que la région stratégique alors que le
liban revendique toujours ces
territoires
alors israël benyamin nétanyahou en plus
précisément le premier ministre
israélien qui a lancé un avertissement
au liban et à la syrie il tiendra en
tout cas responsable ces deux pays s'il
ya une nouvelle tentative de
déstabilisation du territoire israélien
est ce qui est un risque d'embrasement
avec cette tension à la frontière nord
et les possibilités parce que toute la
région passe dans une phase de tensions
avant les élections américaines les les
américains qui ont perdu leur influence
au territoire syrien ils veulent
revendiquer une partie de cette
influence la en irak et au liban
alors il essaie toujours de d'exercer
des pressions sur l'état libanais pour
isoler et booba en même temps et les
dépressions économique et pour cette
raison là ils vont absolue et toutes
tentatives occidentales ce retour de la
part de la france pour intervenir et
aider le liban alors qu'on sait très
bien que le liban et la france ont des
relations historiques qui datent du
xviie siècle - alors c'est cela prépare
l'environnement pour une escale une
escale à sion de la situation et
impossibilité de guerre régionale mai
peut être un peu hésitant à cause du
fait que la résistance libanaise a assez
de pouvoir pour rallier pour éviter des
dommages très grande sur les israéliens
des pertes majeures sur les i try merci
à vous deux malheureux hakim d'avoir
région en direct de beyrouth je rappelle
que vous êtes professeur donc d'histoire
contemporaine et de relations
internationales à l'université libanaise
merci à vous